at the top of the show we had that
riveting tease when i said we're going
to talk about las vegas history
yes now's the time we're going back in
time man
jc we were talking about jc's sin city
chronicles of course it's time for tbt
for this week take a look
all right it's time for this week's sin
city chronicles a weekly look back at
vegas history and happenings
the 714 room marina hotel and casino
opened on may first 1975 at las vegas
boulevard in tropicana
and it still exists today i know what
you're saying
that is where the mgm grand is located
but fun fact look here
the mgm was built as an add-on to the
marina hotel
the mgm bought it in 1989 and everything
was gutted for the new mgm grand
but the marina hotel building it's still
there today
las vegas headliner danny ganz passed
away on may 1st
2009 at the age of 52. the man of many
voices was voted
show of the year for 10 years straight
danny first performed at the
stratosphere then moved to the mirage
and encore at one point his marquee on
the strip
was the largest freestanding marquee in
the world
the stratosphere opened on april 29
1996.
the night included six minutes of
fireworks
it stands at one thousand one hundred
and forty nine feet
but check this out bob stupak's original
plan
had it at eighteen hundred feet the faa
said oh
no way now stupak also wanted to have a
70 foot tall
animatronic ape climbing one of the legs
of the tower obviously that didn't
happen
the aladdin was imploded on april 27
1998
there it goes to make way for the new
aladdin so the hotel it opened up in
1962
as the tally ho it became the aladdin in
1966
and it estimated there they are 20 000
people watched the implosion
nearby the aladdin had a lot of history
on may first 1967
elvis married priscilla the two were
engaged for five months
members of the press were invited to a
press conference that took place between
the ceremony and the champagne brunch
elvis and priscilla were married for six
years
that's your sin city chronicles for the
last week of april